welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and christopher nolan's tenet
is one film that somehow will release in
theaters in coming months the one that
saved us from months of
limited movie news with a new trailer to
break down
and even though it seems like an
indecipherable 4d puzzle what the
best based on some easy to overlook
clues i think i might have figured out
what tennant is all about so let's break
this down frame by frame and spoiler
warning in case i reveal too much
let's get started okay we start with
some footage that we saw in the previous
trailer a ship moving in reverse through
these wind turbines but notice that the
close-up of martin donovan's character
shows a wake that appears to move
outward in normal forward time
it's hard to tell because all he says in
the shot is the word tenet
which is a palindrome both textually and
phonetically
for all we know this trailer could have
reversed the shot and kept the audio the
same
making this whole trailer breakdown
process real fun
as i explained in our breakdown of first
trailer tenet's palindrome aspect
reflects how this whole movie uses
localized time and manipulation
moving forward and backward all of
christopher nolan's films play with time
to some degree
time dilation and dreams times
relationship with gravity
but here it's all about inverting the
flow of time localized within
a system certain characters can reverse
time on certain objects
to gain an advantage in combat or
espionage scenarios
john david washington stares at this
grunt on the left
who out of nowhere winces in pain and
doubles over
as if he was attacked by washington's
seconds in the future
striking him as he reversed to this
pre-fight moment
so you beat up one guy in forward time
while you're beating up his friend in
reverse time
more on this as we move on outside
elizabeth debecky's character departs in
a car
the background passes a black london
taxi placing this
in london her bodyguard who escorts her
out of the kitchen
to the car was also the grunt on the
right in the kitchen who fought
washington
and outside beside washington there's a
guy on the ground as he watches a car
leave so what's really going on here
well i think washington is trying to
intercept
becky's character trying to catch her at
her departure point from the restaurant
and he fights the guards around her the
guy
from outside back to inside the kitchen
and before i move on yes the music
throughout this is incredible it's
composed by ludwig jorgensen
who won an oscar for black panther and
composed the amazing mandalorian score
this guy is on fire let's move on the
new shot to point out is washington with
clement's poecy's technician character
she opens this drawer containing odds
and ends there's
lens pieces rings hardware they're all
small and able to be held
like nolan's inception now both of them
are wearing these green gloves
and one of these pieces floats up to his
gloved hand
which is interesting because this isn't
reverse time if you play it in reverse
the object doesn't drop from gravity and
like wobble when it lands it just kind
of
back in place so it seems like gravity
itself is being inverted
and right before he summons it up
washington seems to be pumping something
in his hand
maybe this is something that primes his
hand to invert the physics like this
but he needs to wear gloves because if
it touches its skin it can be dangerous
let's move on michael kane comes back as
he does in all nolan films he brings up
a sudden
russian national cup 2 kenneth branagh's
character supposedly the antagonist of
this film
a close-up in the last trailer showed
him holding debecky's hand so i'm
guessing she could be his wife or his
lover
maybe his ex one of those things
washington's voiceover says he can
communicate with the future
and assuming we're still talking about
brannock here it seems as if this guy is
a rogue figure
exploiting this technology to manipulate
past events
and that makes them obviously dangerous
and must be stopped by
more altruistic time manipulator agents
now this mysterious concrete chamber
shows up again and again
aaron taylor johnson's gonna be in this
movie he shows up here as this soldier
in the beret
he faces some threat coming out of this
circular door this room is bathed in
red light though notice on the
reflection on the floor coming from the
other side of the glass
suggested that side is lit in blue keep
this
keep this color code in mind as we look
at a clue that shows up in the next
section that explains what all this is
robert pattinson seems to be playing the
newcomer partner to washington
and they clarify that this is not a
trophy time travel movie but rather one
about what they call
inversion and again there seems to be
some tricky editing here
washington is leaning forward when
pattinson asks about time travel but
when we cut to washington's angle
he's sitting back in his chair when he
starts to lean forward to correct him so
again we just can't really trust any of
the sequencing here the technician in
washington they're both
still wearing the gloves as they demo
reverse firing a bullet catching a
bullet they open the chamber to catch
the casing he re-aims the gun
he catches the bullet from the target
bullet goes back in the shell which is
now back in the magazine but the most
important detail of the trailer is this
dry erase board
its equations aren't just random set
decoration that equation
is actually part one of the maxwell
equation with a diagram of what's called
maxwell's demon what okay these relate
to the second law of thermodynamics
and a physics concept that's called
entropy entropy is
well in the loosest sense the measure of
general disorder in the universe the
infinity for particles to chaotically
drift apart from each other but in
physics more specifically it's the
amount of unavailable thermal energy in
a closed system
that can be converted to mechanical work
so if you remember from your high school
physics the second law of thermodynamics
states that the total
entropy can never decrease entropy is a
constant in our universe
it always increases toward a
thermodynamic equilibrium
so we see maxwell's equation that kind
of sums this all up d
u equals t d s minus p dv
means that internal energy u changes
based on
entropy s and volume v but beneath this
gives us a visual depiction
shows maxwell's thought experiment of
two closed systems one with red
particles one with
blue particles and a little demon
underneath who can magically violate the
second law of thermodynamics and entropy
to open a door between these systems
which allows the red and the blue
particles
to mix if this were possible
theoretically
natural constants like the natural
disorder of the universe
or time would no longer be fixed on
perpetually
increasing axes but reversible
this whole chamber in the movie is
maxwell's demon thought experiment
one side red the other side blue they're
a bridge between
parallel realities in which time is
moving in opposite directions
the circular portal in the middle is the
demon door that allows travelers from
one side to interfere with the other
system reverse the motion of the bodies
maybe crossover weapons or vehicles that
move in this reverse vector this demon
door appears to be heavily guarded which
makes sense you don't want people
crossing over but if someone knows what
they're doing
like brano's character they could break
through and wreak havoc
on the causality of the other side's
history maybe this is why they have to
wear oxygen masks when they cross over
they need the air they breathe to be
from their home system
since particles behave differently on
the other side they need to be able to
regulate the air intake so that it
doesn't screw up the flow of
oxygen into their own bloodstream look i
know this is confusing but i'm sure
nolan's script will explain it all more
clearly than i am currently doing
but in shout out exposition over and
over again throughout all the action
yeah you know some of these details are
tough to spot blending seamlessly with
the background kind of like a
what the heck is this a sleek front
pocket wallet like the ridge
thanks to the rich for sponsoring this
video the ridge wallet is light and
sleek and
industrial it's designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky 90s
style back pocket wallets that give you
a
big ass this one is their titanium black
design
it's smooth it's minimalist blends in
seamlessly and
that titanium and hey folks when you go
up for essentials these days just take
the minimal essentials with you to make
for quick hassle-free transactions right
the ridge wallet comes in over 30
thousand colors including carbon fiber
and burnt to titanium it holds up to 12
cars and still has room for cash
assuming you still use those dusty old
greenbacks
every ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they'll let you test drive
it for 45 days
and send it back for a full refund if
you don't love it it's got 30 000 5 star
reviews so they're doing something right
they also have great backpacks and
travel bags with rfid blocking pockets
and optional device charging batteries
father's day is coming up in june and
the ridge wallet would make a great gift
for pops ridge wallets are chainsaw
proof
so when dad trips in the garage he
doesn't have to worry about a touch-up
on that vasectomy oh boy get 10 off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description right here the
painting behind pattinson has a similar
artistic style as the works of francis
bacon
a painter that christopher nolan is
obsessed with he actually pulled out a
big book of bacon
when talking about heath ledger's face
paint design in the dark knight bacon's
work expresses an existentialist bleak
outlook of figures destabilizing
into their raw components a very entropy
influenced idea
or you know maybe it's just hotel wall
art i wrote your comment for you
washington drives a boat out to this big
yacht earlier we saw him in a different
vessel
with no overhang there's just a lot of
different boats in this movie
makes me wonder if maybe that could be
part of the time resetting structuring
theme like
going from being adrift in the chaotic
sea back to the order of land on a
mission
one theory that i saw is that maybe
dubiki's character might have drowned
during a voyage with her husband
and his obsession might be trying to
reverse entropy and time to get her back
and save his family
but i'm also seeing evidence of another
theory okay we circle around washington
and pattinson
and himesh patel nolan actually use
similar camera work on the three heads
of gotham in the dark knight
dent gordon batman as they plotted to
save the city there's more footage of
this
crazy estonian car chase sequence
washington is flipped over in a wrecked
car
branham creeps up with a gun behind him
crossfire
shatters the car window but it's in
reverse suggesting that patented could
be
catching bullets past him as he's moving
in reverse motion brandon's voiceover
says
this is where our worlds collide
suggesting he
is from a different world a different
system where things are moving in
reverse
in his view allowing him to meddle here
washington is in a train yard where one
train moves forward the other in reverse
again expressing this idea of parallel
things moving in opposite directions
moving on okay back to the crazy chase
footage the silver car between the audi
suv
and the bmw flips now the bmw is
speeding in reverse
and watching patterson react pattinson
turns around
suggesting they are the ones in the
beamer reversing then the silver car
flips
back and a normal drive swerving back
from that audi suv which has a dent on
its side
suggesting that moments earlier
deliberately bumped into that silver car
try to slam it into washington pattinson
from their point of view the car
flips in the opposite flow of time than
from the audi's point of view and they
look over to see a mercedes to their
right
reversing just as they are with its back
door opening up to try to intercept the
audi i think they're on the same side
onto the next part so now
a version of pattinson and a version of
washington are on different sides of
this
maxwell system chamber on patents inside
you can see a red marker on the floor
washington's a blue reflection so
clearly these are the red and blue
chambers of that thought experiment i
also pointed out in the last trailer
fundy deal here in one angle pattinson's
hair is messy
immediately after on the other side it
is neatly combed
so we may be looking at the midpoint of
the movie's palindrome here
on patins inside he is on the other side
of the fight hair messed up
about to reverse to its comb state those
bullet holes were caused by washington's
struggle with the soldier which he's
about to go through
after that soldier comes through the
demon door on the other side
and these bullet holes were the focus of
the very first teaser that nolan
released in theaters and they were
surrounded by wisps of smoke and vapor
that appeared to be moving in reverse
perhaps these holes are a key to the
plot the holes would allow air particles
from one side to interfere with the
entropy of the other side
washington and pattinson's mission could
be to patch those holes both these here
and other bigger scary branos size holes
and i love how as the bullet holes
reverse back into the gun here
george's score includes a grip reverse
sound effect
as nolan did with the edith piaf song
and inception it looks like he will once
again rely on
music and sound effects to convey the
passage of time
studying a big sequence in the symphony
hall i'm assuming we will be toggling
between forward music and reverse music
to know which side of it we're on the
whole symphonic element is just very
interesting to me by the way nolan is
shooting these sequences at european
opera houses
and the word opera appears with tenet
and the famous latin seder square which
is a
two-dimensional palindrome matrix that i
think a lot of this could be based on
check out my first breakdown for more on
that these masked gunmen are holding
these hostages at the symphony in
ukraine
this sequence was actually for the
movie's prologue showed at imax
screenings in december washington and
his team of extractors
pose as real cops to extract an american
who they say has been made i guess the
ukrainians set up this whole terrorist
attack as a blind to cover up this
american's death so watch it in the
american exchange is cryptic code phrase
we live in a twilight world and there
are no friends at dusk they end up
swapping clothes between this guy and
one of their agents so the guy they're
trying to extract can just escape on his
own and all the chaos washington gets
saved by a mystery man who
reverses the bullet back through a real
cop and even though the terrorist event
isn't really their mission washington
saves the cat by throwing all the bombs
in the opera box and during this all the
hostages are passed out because the cops
were pumping knockout gas through the
vents
which is making some believe this could
be based on the 2002
moscow dubrovka theater attack by armed
chechens very tragic 170 people died but
this prologue ends with washington's
driver saying that they extracted the
wrong guy
got the switcheroo and then i'm thinking
this leads to the train yard sequence
that cyanide moment we've seen another
footage
that could be what leads to the tenant
organization coming in
reversing washington's killing and
recruiting him to their forces and
before we move on we see
it's the audi suv that's reversing with
washington trying to get
becky out of it before it crashes into
the traffic ahead reynold counts down as
he points a gun at her so maybe opposed
to trying to save his wife it's also
possible that she defected from him
told other authorities about his evil
inversion plans and now he's reversing
back to try to kill her before she can
tell others what he's up to
my head hurts washington asks the key
question of this premise that
if we can reverse the flow of time if
we're here right now
doesn't it mean that what we're worried
about never happened well i think the
implication is that our very existence
means that entropy agents are constantly
scrambling behind the scenes
to evade all kinds of temporal disasters
that were lucky to sidestep
but now washington has to join these
meticulous resetters to keep the
universe from collapsing into chaos he
has to bear the burden of all that
stress
okay i just gotta pause here to
over-obsess about this tenet title
obviously it's a palindrome but the
letters disappear in an interesting way
it starts with the
middle in popping out of existence but
the e's both
slide back together but the t's
disappear a different way each of them
themselves is symmetric
disappearing individually from the
outside in this might reflect the
movie's structure
maybe the movie starts in the middle but
with dual
timelines one in which washington is the
more experienced explain the patents and
how it works but he recruits
him because he knows he's his partner in
the other timeline in the future
and then another timeline progresses
backwards to his earlier time when he
was less experienced
on to the last bit okay nolan appears to
be topping his plane crash sequence from
the dark knight rises but with a
ground-paced plane crash somehow
so what is the real mission here well
there was a separate tv spot that came
out that went a bit further into this so
i think the mission is to either break
into this plane or the building it's
crashing into
washington and pattinson are disguising
as swat with a body in a body bag that
might be patel
sneaking inverted in time past
firefighters
onto that plane before it crashes into
the building maybe so that all three of
them could get onto that plane and
hijack it and fly it somewhere else
and finally these end titles could not
be clearer about this movie opening
in theaters the whole theatrical
cinematic experience is very very
important to directors like christopher
nolan they're not into streaming and
while it's still a bit unclear about the
exact release date it looks like the
studio is still hoping for a july
release as planned
we will see but comment down below with
your theories also spend the shutdown
period by watching along to classic
films and breaking them down with us on
our official discord server by becoming
a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign